well today's the day almost everyone is
back at work and most of the kids are
back in school the new year has
officially started the traffic is back
up and we start our rhythm with our new
goals and our new mindset on our new
resolutions and our new fresh clean
clear year in front of us so what are
you gonna do with it
what are you gonna do with this year
people who win when intentionally
winning is not an accidental thing they
never interview someone at the end of
the Super Bowl and say how did you win
and he says I don't know I just get off
the bus and it just happened no it's an
intentional act as a matter of fact it's
a whole series of intentional acts that
get you to be world class in your
category your world class in your career
your world class in your marriage your
world class in your parenting you're a
world class mom it's an intentional act
it doesn't just accidentally happen
people choose to put things into their
life behaviors habits and they choose to
change to get better and by the way if
you've not chosen to get better you have
by default chosen to get worse because
nothing stays the same you're either
growing or you're dying baby and every
relationship you're in is either growing
or it's dying everything you're doing is
either growing or dying
it's either getting better or it's
getting worse and a lot of it has to do
with your choice do I have big dreams
good we're gonna do about them
I like having big dreams but if you stop
there you're what's known as a dreamer
which is not someone most of us want
dating our daughter you don't want to
just be a dreamer you want to be a doer
it starts with a dream but a dream with
work clothes on is called a goal it's
not a rose
illusion that's gone by Valentine's Day
you can't find any room in the gym this
week but by Valentine's Day every
machine will be open no problem just
wait a few weeks it'll drop off a cliff
and you'll have all your machines back
if you keep going goals that work must
be specific they must be measurable they
must have a time limit I want to lose
some weight this year it's measurable
but not specific and doesn't have a time
limit I won't lose 30 pounds in 90 days
now we have the beginnings of a goal
it's specific it's measurable it has a
time limit has to be your goal my wife
wants me to lose 30 pounds you're not
gonna do it
not gonna do it at all my mom always
wanted me to be a dentist I don't want
to be your patient I don't want you to
let it I don't I don't be hanging out
with people living other people's goals
through their body no live your goals
what is it you own what is it the juice
is your brain up and makes you go I
gotta go do that I can't not do it I
know that's a double negative but I
don't care it's my show I can't not do
it you can't keep me from doing it I
have to do it and lastly goal should be
in writing now some of you have heard me
talk about this over the last couple of
weeks but some of you were just
rejoining the show because you've been
on vacation and so I want to make sure
you have clearly written specific
measurable goals with a time limit I
want to get out of debt win give it a
time limit specific how much debt are
you gonna pay off in this calendar year
when are you gonna complete your debt
snowball when are you gonna be a
millionaire when you're gonna be a 10
millionaire deca millionaire when are
you gonna double your income what have
you got to do to do that when you're
going to lose that weight when are you
going to increase the quality of that
relationship when you're going to
increase your spiritual walk increase
your connectivity to God when you're
going to get rid of that temper what are
you going to do what's your deal this
year there's seven areas that Zig Ziglar
and many others used to say
they called it the Wheel of Life that
you need to set goals in all these
different areas you need goals in these
seven areas write them down unless
you're driving which case you can just
turn the podcast on later and listen
back seven areas you need goals and you
need financial goals and of course we're
going to talk about those on the Dave
Ramsey show you need intellectual goals
how long has it been since you've read a
book the average millionaire reads a
nonfiction book a month and can't tell
you who got thrown off the island
very few millionaires know anything
about the Kardashians they didn't even
know there were any but they've read a
book pick up a book and read what are
you doing with your intellectual goals
are you taking a class this year if
you're not getting smarter in a culture
and in business where the speed of
change is blinding if you're not getting
smarter every day by definition you're
getting Dumber because you're getting
left behind left behind and then you can
blame it on the systemic problems caused
by the Republicans if you want but you
got left behind because you didn't read
a book read a book
matter of fact read a nonfiction book a
month how many books you're gonna read
this year family goals what are their
nurturing goals for your family what are
your time spent two goals what are the
letters you're gonna write to family
members this year spiritual goals and
read through the Bible this year you're
gonna start attending church you can
start walking with God maybe you need to
reset some of that physical goals almost
every one of us has some physical goals
mine involves many fewer chocolate chip
cookies many fewer and boy do I need to
get off the chocolate chip cookies y'all
pray for me I love chocolate chip
cookies and my body shows it it's bad
you know what makes you think look
thinner than wearing block black being
thinner there you go
I'll help you with that career goals I
hate my job how long are you gonna stay
there when you gonna start listen to the
Ken Coleman and get
on how to do a proper resume how to do a
proper interview how to get in proximity
with a proximity principal number one
best-selling book and get the job that
you love what do you why would you work
somewhere for 30 freakin years with the
people you hate I like what I do but the
people are toxic then get out of there
you know what is this punishment doesn't
have to be toil you could have do I
don't have to make less money why why do
you always have to make less money live
your dreams well who started that rumor
usually living your dreams involves
making more money find a different way
to do it what are your career goals what
are your social goals my wife used to
tell my kids all these cliches growing
up the old-fashioned cliches you don't
you want to have friends you need to be
a friend I mean how long has it been
since you invited someone over for
dinner no so how long has it been since
you actually had dinner at your house
there's an idea saves a lot of money by
the way versus eating out every night
you have social goals you have any
friends maybe you need more friends I
mean you go deeper with some friends
you've got you need to set goals in
those seven areas and they need to be
specific measurable have a time limit in
writing and they need to be your goals I
get your year started baby game all